c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 à la
une ce soir le rwanda qui rejette les
accusations de son voisin congolais
kinshasa que ce qui galy de soutenir les
rebelles du m23 dans l'est du pays le
ministre des affaires étrangères juan
des parle d'accusations sans fondement
nous serons à kigali et à goma dans ce
journal charles blé goudé a obtenu son
passeport l'ancien ministre de laurent
gbagbo à quitter par la cpi de crimes
contre l'humanité le 31 mars 2021 a
finalement pu obtenir ce document après
une longue attente pour l'instant il n'a
fixé aucune date de retour en côte
d'ivoire nous serons à abidjan dans ce
journal et puis ce c puis ce soir nous
allons parler des relations entre
l'afrique et israël en marge d'une
conférence entre des pays du continent
et l'état hébreu
le porte parole de l'ambassade d'israël
à paris est notre invité interview à la
fin de cette édition
les relations entre kigali et kinshasa
ne sont pas au beau fixe la république
démocratique du congo accuse le rwanda
de soutenir les rebelles du m23 et le
rwanda qui rejette ces accusations
accuse de son côté la république
démocratique du congo de soutenir les
fdlr un autre groupe rebelle formé à
part les hutus après le génocide des
tutsis en 1994 les détails avec notre
correspondant à kigali simon wohlfarth
depuis plusieurs jours kigali et
kinshasa sont à couteaux tirés le
ministre rwandais des affaires
étrangères vincent biruta s'est exprimé
ce week-end sur la situation entre les
deux pays lors du sommet de l'union
africaine d'après lui les accusations de
la république démocratique du congo sont
sans fondement et le m23 est un problème
strictement congolais il a à son tour
accusé l'armée congolaise de combattre
aux côtés des fdlr ce groupe rebelle
hutu rwandais qui opère dans l'est de la
rdc les tensions porte également autour
de l'arrestation de deux soldats
rwandais d'apr est égal il aurait été
capturé par les fardc et les fdlr
lors d'une patrouille à la frontière
pourtant les congolais affirme que ces
deux militaires ont été capturés non au
rwanda mais à 20 km à l'intérieur de
leur territoire preuve pour kinshasa
d'une incursion rwandaise
il ya une semaine des roquettes venus du
congo sont tombés sur le sol rwandais
faisant plusieurs blessés d'après un
communiqué de l'armée rwandaise kigali
des lions dénonce alors une provocation
leur honda sur choisir la voie
diplomatique et saisi un organisme de
vérification régionales si les relations
entre le rwanda et la rdc s'était
améliorée depuis l'élection du président
congolais félix tshisekedi la résurgence
du m23 marque un point final à cette
période de détente
en réaction la rdc a suspendu les vols
de la compagnie rwandair sur son
territoire et convoqué l'ambassadeur du
rwanda au congo et puis sachez pour être
complet que le président sénégalais
macky sall président en exercice de
l'union africaine s'est dit dimanche
gravement préoccupé par la montée de la
tension entre le rwanda et la république
démocratique du congo exhortant les deux
pays au calme et au dialogue
on prend à présent la direction de la
côte d'ivoire charles blé goudé l'ancien
ministre de laurent gbagbo
définitivement acquittés par la cour
pénale internationale de crimes contre
l'humanité le 31 mars 2021 a finalement
obtenu son passeport ivoirien il avait à
plusieurs reprises accusé les autorités
consulaires de son pays de tarder à lui
délivrer ce document d'identité et de
voyage pour l'instant charles blé goudé
n'a fixé aucune date de retour la
correspondance et abidjan danem sergio
rentrer en côte d'ivoire pour apporter
sa pierre à la consolidation de la
réconciliation nationale c'est ce que
promet l'ancien leader du mouvement
nationaliste des jeunes patriotes
charles blé goudé qui plaidait depuis
son acquittement par la cpi en mars 2021
pour l'obtention d'un passeport un droit
qui avait été octroyé à laurent gbagbo
avec l'accord du président ouattara en
décembre 2020 et avait permis de
concrétiser son retour dans le pays il
ya près d'un an le président du cojep le
congrès panafricain des jeunes et des
patriotes a lui tenu à exprimer sa
reconnaissance au président ivoirien je
cite pour son implication personnelle
dans le processus de son retour en côte
d'ivoire d une étape importante vient
d'être franchie et au siège de son parti
où nous nous trouvons et bien ses
partisans de cash ni leur soulagement
dire leur enthousiasme face à cette
perspective comme vous et moi il a eu
une main tenant et son passeport nous
l'attendons nous attendons maintenant
son du tout et nous avons la filme la
ferme conviction que ce que j ai
recommencé la ive a terminé nous
attendons j'admire auditoire c'est
pourquoi mes gars semblent eux il est
bon pour rouler que les ivoiriens et
nous sommes prêts à temps pour
l'accompagner dans cette voie là bientôt
nous allons approcher donc depuis
voisine pour qu'ensemble nous puissions
pratique pour son retour en côte
d'ivoire je rappelle que blé goudé avait
été arrêté en 2013 au ghana avant d'être
transféré à la cpi en 2014 suite à son
acquittement par la cour il avait
demandé réparation pour les huit années
passées en prison ou en liberté
conditionnelle une demande qui a été
rejetée en février et puis comme à
l'ancien président laurent gbagbo
charles blé goudé a été condamné par
contumace en côte d'ivoire à 20 ans de
prison pour des faits est liée à la
crise post électorale une condamnation
qui n'a officiellement pas été levées
mais elle n'a pas été appliquée à
l'encontre de laurent gbagbo depuis son
retour
dans la zone l'actualité en bref et en
images ce rapport de la mission des
nations unies au mali selon la minus ma
le nombre de morts civils et de violence
des droits imputables à l'armée malienne
soutenue par des militaires étrangers a
connu une hausse exponentielle au
premier trimestre de 2022 la mission de
l'onu dans le pays a dénombré 320 cas
les groupes armés affiliés à al-qaïda ou
à l'organisation et à islamique restent
les principaux auteurs de violences
contre les civils dans pays en guinée
l'onu a exhorté les militaires au
pouvoir de rétablir le droit de
manifester sur la voie publique les
autorités de transition avait décrété
l'interdiction des manifestations à
caractère politique une mesure entrée en
vigueur le 13 mai dernier le championnat
d'afrique de judo fut une compétition
organisée à oran dans l'ouest de
l'algérie la sélection algérienne de
judo a d'ailleurs été sacrée championne
d'afrique par équipes mixtes ce dimanche
en clôture de la 43e édition de
l'épreuve continentale
notre invité ce soir et le porte parole
de l'ambassade d'israël à paris il est
venu nous parler des relations afrique
israël en marge d'une conférence entre
le continent et l'état hébreu bonsoir
ciment c'est aussi merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau en forme pour parler
de ses relations entre l'afrique et
l'état hébreu alors l'état hébreu a
normalisé ses relations avec de nombreux
pays africains c'est le cas par exemple
du rwanda de l'ouganda c'est aussi le
cas plus récemment du soudan et du maroc
pour le maroc et le sou et le soudan
c'est normalisation souvent été
qualifiés de rapprochement de
circonstance le maroc en échange de la
reconnaissance du sahara occidental à
normaliser ses relations avec israël
pour le soudan il s'agissait plutôt de
de lever les sanctions américaines sur
le pays est ce que ces rapprochements ne
sont pas finalement voué à s'étendre sur
le continent je suis je ne suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec vous
tout d'abord il ne s'agit pas uniquement
du soudan et du maroc mais aussi du
tchad avec lequel nous avons normaliser
les relations il ya quelques années d'un
retour en tant qu'observateurs à l'union
africaine plus globalement il y a
un réel retour d'israël en afrique un
réchauffement comme l'a dit notre mise
affaires étrangères ce n'est pas un
slogan c'est une réalité diplomatique
économique sociale qui est bien sûr
aussi basée sur des intérêts c'est
évident nous ne nions pas et c'est en
renforçant la coopération qui est basé
aussi sur des intérêts qu'on arrive à
créer des liens forts et je pense que
dans de nombreux domaines que ce soit
l'agriculture l'eau la technologie aussi
le sécuritaire israël a des atouts
importants qui sont pertinents pour la
croissance que traversent de nombreuses
nations du continent aujourd'hui il ya
parfois des rapprochements plus fragiles
que d'autres notamment avec des pays
musulmans dont les bonnes relations
peuvent fluctuer en fonction de la
flambée de violence au proche orient je
pense notamment au sénégal c'est un pays
où qui créent qui a construit des
relations avec l'état hébreu mais où
l'opinion publique reste quand même très
pro palestinienne ya nombreuses
manifestations dans le pays pro
palestinienne et l'opinion publique
reproche parfois aux autorités
sénégalaises ce rapprochement avec
israël est ce que cette opinion publique
ne va pas l'emporter sur pareil sur la
realpolitik
est ce que vous ne craignez pas qu'il ya
certains pays où les relations sont plus
fragiles encore une fois il ya l'afrique
est un continent gigantesque
il ya des des zones avec lesquels nous
avons des relations extrêmement proches
depuis des décennies d'autres avec
lesquels ses plus récents globalement je
pense que de nombreuses populations
africaines de nombreuses nations
africaines ont une image très positive
d'israël israël qui historiquement a
toujours collaboré avec l'afrique ce
soir les années 60-70
dans divers ce domaine et je pense que
[Musique]
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on voit ce que
l'afrique est en train de traverser
lorsqu'on regarde un petit peu en avant
10 ans 20 ans et qu'on se projette et
qu'on voit les défis auxquels de
nombreux pays vont faire face pour pour
se développer pour devenir un continent
central dans la géopolitique dans
l'économie mondiale de nombreux pays
africains vont chercher des partenariats
pour pouvoir se développer et ils vont
chercher des partenariats avec des avec
des pays qui qui qui les ont toujours
regardé
d'égal à égal israël vous savez en 74
ans on a de notre existence on a relevé
d'immenses défis dans le domaine de
l'agriculture dans le domaine de l'eau
de la sécurité et c'est des défis qui
sont pertinents pour de nombreuses zones
afrique alors merci beaucoup asim ans
est aussi porte-parole de l'ambassade
d'israël c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous tout de suite
la suite de paris direct avec audrey
racines
[Musique]